does it [ __ ] with your head this is a
crazy question but does it [ __ ] with
your head when you see like
pete now is you know he dated ariana
grande
and then colin marries scarlett
johansson
are you like [ __ ] i gotta marry somebody
like
really
but why michael in other words i would
think that's a great
uh why don't i think that's a great
thing
tell me i don't understand first of all
okay this is just for me i don't know i
don't know if this is an unpopular thing
to say
famous relationships seem
miserable to me like they ju it's so
much harder
for two famous people to get together
and
uh combine
forces of attention you know yes
and and press and constant scrutiny it's
it's hard it's a very very hard thing to
do
like if you're in love and it's and it's
beautiful i
i totally get it but for someone to like
for me to think to date someone like
that i'm like oh my god that seems like
so much work
how are you going to uh find someone i i
would think
not at work because everybody's in show
business the sad thing is too it's just
like
like we meet we see when you're in this
world it's like well who else are you
gonna date everybody you know that's
like a normal
good person you know you know like i
think colin met scarlett here
and it's like yes yeah you talk to them
you get to be a regular person here and
you get to see people for who they are
here
uh but outside of that is the industry
you know that other industry where it's
not snl where it's not
you know there's no security here and
there's no you know paparazzi
here where you're in the middle of that
it's exhausting you know
those parties and it's it's rough i i'd
much rather
meet somebody normal you must be wild
because scarlett johansson
said she did not want you planning
colin's uh bachelor party
under any circumstances why is she so
afraid of you
that uh does she know there's gonna be
like you're gonna do something really
[ __ ] up is that the
is that the answer no i don't think i
don't think so i think uh
no she she was probably just saying that
for the cameras maybe i don't know
but she's also fun like that's that's my
favorite thing about
their relationship is if you knew them
they're they're the same people like
they're so
they're perfect for each other you know
like they're just they're they're
for the same reason i like i love colin
i love her i know lorne michaels a
little bit
and i'm gonna say to him the next time i
see him i'm gonna say you know what
michael che is a really good guy um and
you tell me who do you want to host
saturday night live that we can set you
up with
uh who is that dreamer lauren go through
his roller derby
thank you find the perfect mate
the sexiest thing a woman can ask me is
so what do you do
that is beautiful thank you yes
i just want a nice boring librarian
nobody famous
you